this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house greetings
from podcastville you bad [__]
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
relief ban
listen there's plenty to be anxious
about today so when i say relief ban
helps me with my anxiety you know it's
the real deal relief ban has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
prevent anxiety based
nausea and vomiting do you deal with
nausea from motion sickness migraines
hangovers morning sickness or
chemotherapy relief band can help you
with that it's like the name says it's a
band you wear on your wrist to give you
relief from nausea caused by things like
anxiety you change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker it's very simple
listen
after my surgery i got really before i
got the surgery somebody sent me a
relief ban i didn't know who the hell it
was i thought it was the doctor
so when i had the surgery i put it on
and my agent told me they were one of
the sponsors so it was very easy i loved
it by that point relief ban is 100
drug-free non-drowsy and provides
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects and they just released their
relief band sport it's waterproof has an
extended battery life and attaches to
your apple or android watch who's better
than relief bad nobody listen you got an
uncle an aunt a grandfather somebody
who's going through nausea because of
what they're going through relief bend
makes a great gift for any time of the
year right now you get the exclusive
offer
just for the joint listeners you ready
for this what i'm going to do for you
guys on a wednesday if you go to
reliefband.com
and use promo code joey you'll receive
20 off
plus free shipping and no questions
asked with a 30 day money back guarantee
that's the best offer you'll find on
relief banned anywhere but you have to
use my code joey j-o-e-y
so head to reliefband.com use promo code
jewelry for 20 off and free shipping a
relief ban i'll tell you it makes a
perfect gift and i love you for it
relief band code joey the joint is also
brought to you by draftkings listen
the action started already what are you
waiting on it's the biggest college
basketball tournament of the year and
draftking sportsbook is ready for you
turn your team's victory into your win
what we're gonna do this week at
draftkings
five dollars on any team to win and get
dollars in free bets to pull you through
the whole month of march so you keep
winning some money and if they win you
win if you when i win if sportsbook
isn't available to you in your state yet
then you can still join the college
hoops action with draftkings pools
everyone can play free pools all
all march long for a shot at over 250
000 in prizes download the draftking
sports book app now use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
bet 5 hours on any college hoops team to
win and get 200 miles and free bets if
they do if they win you win with promo
code joey
this week at draftkings sportsbook 21
over restrictions apply
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion listen
when it comes to cbd line they're the
best cbd available on the market how do
i know
because i've been with them for four
years this is all i take i take the
gummies to sleep i take the tincture for
well-being listen if your elbow hurts
they got the cream they got the patches
and the kinesiology tape cbd lion has it
all do me a favor go to cbdline.com read
the third party lab results
listen it doesn't compare it's the best
on the market by a long shot it relaxes
you it helps you sleep
and it withdraw it restores health guys
they don't want you to have cbd in your
system but uncle joey does so go to
cbdline.com right now
press and code joey or church and get 20
percent off delivered to your
[__] house
get the party started with cbd lion
let's get our party started too it's
wednesday morning [__] let's do
this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 16th
of march the day before saint patty's
day i [__] love saint patty's day
even though i don't drink and [__]
my uh
my neighbors up the corner gonna make a
couple [__] uh
whatever the [__] corned beefs
we're gonna go over there on [__]
thursday
smoke some reef i'm gonna smoke tons of
reef i'm gonna start like a [__] 3 30
in the afternoon well i'll start a
little earlier than that i usually start
like at 3 30 to prep for dinner is what
i'm trying to say i'll drop a couple of
abx's to get the party started to get
that hunger in there for reals you know
what i'm saying nothing bothers me more
when i go eat and [__] i'm not hungry
you know nothing nothing
and for a long time i wasn't getting
high like last night i went to this
place called [__] harold's
in edison [__] tremendous if you like
corned beef pastrami
brisket
you order a sandwich for two if you walk
in there with six people order a
sandwich for two that's all you need
everybody you'll [__] eat it's this
big this sandwich i got a picture of my
phone they give you this much pastrami
this much brisket and this much [__]
corned beef it's [__] tremendous i
can eat that [__] forever but that's it
after tomorrow night i won't eat it
again until [__] it now who the [__]
i love pastrami guys i've always loved
[__] pastrami the pickled
herring around the corner oh lord they
got good [__] pastrami that jew food
will kill you i love it they got the
original conditions and [__] i love all
that stuff
oh i [__] love canisius with some
with some [__] dry spicy mustard stop
it but anyway i want to talk to you guys
about sunday or monday i'm sorry uh we i
cut you guys off short with the podcast
uh monday my sister died and it took me
my [__] storm it was uh
terrible i got the text the week before
from my niece
saying that my sister wasn't doing too
well she fell ill
and that the doctors gave her like a
week well they don't [__] around in cuba
when they give you a week you die in a
week she died exactly a [__] week
later and it took me by you know
surprise but
she's 68
um
you know i haven't seen her since i was
three
and she was maybe 10 or something like
that who the [__] knows anymore
after uh my mom died we lost contact for
like 20 years and then in 2009 we
reconnected when i started talking to my
uncle again and uh
our relationship was good you know i
tried to invite her here but
she was such a [__] commie she
wouldn't come anyway you know
but i still loved her anyway i
understood um
i'm happy that my sister passed away
because her dream and my mother's dream
and how
[__] they came to fruition they're
with each other
so uh hopefully they're up there jumping
up and down calling each other [__]
names and [__] you know
my mother not having
maggie that's her name maggie my sister
uh
killed her
that was the slowest torture in the
world them getting separated but it was
just story of immigration
you know this isn't something that just
happened to my family this has happened
the families from all over the world and
they migrate to uh to the united states
sometimes a father would come and get
settled and then send back for his kids
it's a [__] painful
to live without your kids i know first
hand
but uh my mother went through it and it
was sad to see it go through that in the
daytime she'd be a barrel of laps and
then at night once she was by herself
the pain would creep up on them you know
we all have that you know when we're
it's like when uh somebody close to you
passes away
you know for a couple months you're fine
in the daytime you're around people
you're at work you're with your friends
you're giggling
at night when you're by yourself it
weighs heavy on you so
it weighed on my mother for years and i
i know it weighed on my sister
because even when i spoke to her when we
didn't talk for a long time and then we
reconnected
we would have conversations and she
would tell me that
you know her mother told us she was
coming back for her and my mother never
left in cuba
fidel closed the [__]
borders he wouldn't let anybody in or
travel we hired attorneys we did
everything we could
politicians tried to help us and we
could never get my sister out and then
she ended up marrying one of [__]
castro soldiers so
she made a life for herself there i uh
i'm a little sad you know i never got
the
i never got closure with her to see her
we spoke plenty on the phone and uh i'm
good with that you know what i'm saying
i'm one of those guys that hey
i'll work it out i'll call [__]
better help next week and talk to them
and process this the right way because i
don't want this to come back and bite me
in the ass later so
i'm going to process this i'm going to
grief this the right way and it's funny
we just had jesuit paluso on here
speaking about grief you know
listen everybody's going through this
right now uh the last two years
everybody's lost somebody a friend a
relative an uncle an aunt
and we all feel a little weird this was
my [__] uh whatever
my sister gone but hey
let's move the [__] on it's a great
[__] week tomorrow saint patty's day
beside eating corned beef tomorrow i
don't know what i'm gonna do i still
remember [__] getting a bus
and we used to do uh like i did it one
year i didn't really
what am i talking about
corki my friend gregory seven day
weekend he would get a bus and we would
all get on the bus and stop at all the
irish bars and the city and
do the crawl oh
it's insane the bus smell like puke
everything smells like [__] puke but
it's a great day you know there's always
something going on you know my
daughter's excited about i'm excited
about it who the [__] knows a couple
weeks ago i was listening to you know in
the car i have siriusxm
so i listened to a lot of classic vinyl
i listened to a lot of ozzie's boneyard
i listened to octane i listened to disco
studio 54.
they got great stations 70s
70s by 70s 80s and the 80s i don't
[__] know they're all
real lithium is great they're all great
stations you know and uh
last week i mean i've known a jelly roll
for a long time we're like friends you
know but
i thought he was more of a rapper you
know and i've been caught up in my own
world with music the last couple of
years
a couple weeks ago on octane
he did a two-hour show or an hour show
or something on octane and i was in the
car driving and it was one of those
things that you don't want to get out of
the car you want to finish this concert
it was like a couple years ago guns and
roses ended their tour at the forum and
it was a monday night and i never forget
that i went out
my neighbors had gone for the guns and
roses tickets they told me they had a
box
but i had a podcast that night and i'm
never forget coming home from the
podcast
and listening to the live guns and roses
from that show they were there right as
it was going on they were taping and
it's serious and uh
broadcasting and [__] slash was going
off jack
like slash was going [__] off and i'm
like damn i wish i was there this is how
it was
with octane with [__] jelly roll his
voice sounded
so [__] tremendous it's so deep
it's so soulful you know that dead man
walk and he's got a couple songs
that are [__] tremendous well after i
heard the octane
i called them up like a [__]
man and i said listen i gotta have you
on the podcast
cause you my friend on your way up you
know
uh
it's just tremendous music you know i
even let my wife listen to it
because she's from nashville his voice
is so [__] soulful it's like barry
white
meets the temptations meets johnny cash
meets [__] you know
it's tremendous but anyway judge for
yourself
we did a little [__] uh
zoom i hope you enjoy it this is my man
jelly roll give him some love six one
five
[Music]
uncle joey
welcome to the joint my brother what's
happening jelly
man i am awesome dude
how are you today my friend
dude uncle joey i got to do the coolest
thing over you knew this because we
talked over the weekend i got to wake up
this morning hung over
and announced my red rock show on
morning radio in denver colorado
holy [__] i know you were talking uh the
guy hit me up from columbus
you know what's crazy i called him after
our boy loper
randy razor yeah i [__] loved them
i've known them since florida
yeah yeah she's getting prettier every
time i [__] see her she's getting
hotter and
she's got like hotter
kids she's [__] beautiful
yeah she's getting younger and he's
getting older this is the typical
typical marriage right like me and my
wife yeah that good [__] people how
long you been married for jealous i've
been married going all seven years wow
do you have children
oh yeah children i got a uh i got a uh
almost she's all she'll be 14 in like
a month we got full custody of her we've
had full custody of her since she was
eight or seven
so i guess seven eight years now almost
and um i got a seven-year-old boy
six-year-old boy [__] tremendous huh
yeah they will see you perform
oh yeah no bailey performs with me i'm
gonna send you a clip when we hang up so
my daughter writes raps
she writes songs she plays the piano she
plays the guitar
she's she's incredible man this kid is
like golden she's everything it's just
insane and she's got a cool story uncle
joey so her mother
had had a belt with heroin an addiction
early in bailey's life so i ended up
getting full custody of her you know and
my wife took her in and raised her as
her own she calls my wife mama and her
biological mom mom which i'm proud to
say
her mother's sober now but her mother
had about a five five year period where
she just you know just kind of
disappeared you know and uh
bailey came to me when she was like
eight or nine you know kind of mad about
it and i was like well just write it out
you know that's how i used to deal with
my stuff when i was your age just tried
it out and i thought she'd you know
write how she felt because she get
emotional you know
this kid came back with a rap uncle joey
he went upstairs like her daddy thought
i might go write a song about it and the
kid came back with like a rap
about how she felt about you know the
situation so
it was awesome man i ended up putting
her on the album and it was just cool
man so she gets on like every other
album now the kid has published you know
like my last four albums where she
writes on
that's [__] tremendous man
yeah you know
mike and i were just talking about
the music business
it was hard when i was young now it's
even [__] harder and right now
we're catching you on the [__]
upswing
oh i feel in my balls
that you're about to blow up especially
after this tour that you guys have
yes sir this summer that [__] one
show in louisville
yeah i gotta tell you man
i don't i'm not a big festival guy
because you commit you're there all
[__] day dangerous in the heat people
are puking next to you
you smell vd in the air you know it's a
[__] those outdoor
festivals but i tell you
the lineups on that festival are [__]
tempting
oh dude here's the good news huh you
come you ain't got to worry about
dealing with the heat
we'll go from bus to show to bus to show
that's it
yeah for sure well now you must get high
and then we'll get a golf cart to pick
us up go see who wants to see right back
to the bus to get high again
now is are you performing all four days
or just a one day
i just got the one day i think i landed
on the uh the sunday i believe the
sunday and who else is on that show kiss
oh yeah it was kiss i have to look back
at the at the list but i think the foo
fighters uh jane's addiction
uh god it's i mean everybody it's huge
it's like
this it's gonna be the biggest rock
festival in america like attendance-wise
ever
i [__] couldn't believe the bands i
can't believe who's going to be there
that's a great [__] festival
this guy so danny wimmer presents this
guy named danny wemmer he's still one of
the last independent promoters left in
on earth
old school indie guy
and he throws four big festivals a year
incarceration in ohio
rockville down in daytona beach at the
daytona motor speedway
louder than life in louisville kentucky
and aftershock in sacramento and every
one of them are [__] 50 to 100 000
people
huge rock festivals all rock bands old
school i played one year with guns and
roses i got the coolest thing in the
world i took my daughter with me she's
like maybe 10 at the time and i'm
playing like you know at this time i'm
playing like the 115 in the afternoon
slot right on stage seven you know what
i mean like
and uh we're out there rocking you know
we're cutting our teeth and paying our
dues we still had a huge crowd so we
were stoked
and we go to see that an ice cube played
that night before
guns and roses
man so
ice cubes up on stage and he's rocking
and he comes off stage and now keep in
mind my daughter's you know 10.
she don't know on the way there she's
like
what's ice cube doing at this festival
and she's like she knows them from are
we there yet like she knows them from
the movie you know what i mean and i was
like oh wait till you see this [__] so i
play her ice cube the whole way to
louisville you know
and ice cube comes off stage he took a
picture with one person at that whole
festival danny wimmer told me this
himself he took one picture the whole
day he was there and it was with my
daughter so bailey's got a picture with
ice cube it's like one of my pride
possessions of her childhood you know
[__] crazy
yeah and i was so proud of her when she
posted a picture of her joy the caption
said today was a good day
i was like that's my [__] kid dude
that's my [__] kid so we seen guns
and roses that night it's electric you
should come man i'm telling you
let me talk to florentine and florentine
has an older brother that goes to all
those festivals you know the one in
tennessee all of them i thought you were
the one in tennessee when
what's his name fell off the stage last
year right
didn't he fall for the singer from
motley crue
yeah yeah yeah he was all [__] up
yeah vince neil yeah you want to talk
about getting a bad bad hand he was
killing it you know he always gets a bad
rep for like singing sometimes you know
or whatever and he was like they were
like saying he was having like one of
the best vocal performances in 20 years
for 15 years and it walks out there and
misses the [__] step between the
speaker and the stage and [__]
that guy's the kiss of [__] death
he really is the kiss of death and i
love him to death but no he can't when
did you know you wanted to sing brother
man i didn't
i felt limited by options life had
limited my options at that point and i
it's all i've ever wanted to do huh
i like never wanted to do anything i
never liked my mom tells the story
i never wanted to be a firefighter i
never wanted to be a wrestler like i
wasn't like most kids you know i wasn't
like i didn't want to be a police
officer or you know a football player
i wanted to be a rapper i wanted to be a
rocker you know like i wanted to sing i
wanted to write music ever since i was
like seven or eight
you said something very interesting you
said that uh
the limitations
what you had available to you
what do you mean by that
you know so we grew up in a like middle
lower class community
you know at my core my mother was a
bartender my father was a meat salesman
at book bets
so
you didn't see a lot of people where i'm
from to this day
very few people from my little
neighborhood in nashville did anything
you know i still got family members who
have never left my neighborhood
like they've never even come to my shows
on the other side of town
you know what i'm saying it's like in
your world it's like a [__]
girl in brooklyn and never went to
manhattan you know what i'm saying like
yeah
[__] i need to go there for it you know
what i'm saying it's like that's how
they feel you know
i got people the old southern
[__] that are still in that
same trailer park right now it's like
yeah we're just you want to see us come
see us i'm like yo
i like send you a black car to come eat
dinner with me you're like yeah we don't
care you need to bring your big real
hollywood ass this trailer part come
holler at us we're not going nowhere you
know they're just so i just i didn't see
too many options and i knew i wasn't
athletic right
and uh i was been chubby my whole life
and music just kind of was the language
of the neighborhood
you know it's uh
it just spoke to me in a way that the
way i explained it to people uncle was
music is something we felt where i'm
from we didn't listen to
it wasn't background noise
like when certain songs came on you
watch the whole [__] neighborhood
shut the [__] up
you know like everybody was in this song
like you know conversations would stop
if the right song came on the radio you
know
my mother used to sit at the kitchen
table and she'd be smoking cigarettes
right my mother you'd love her to death
uncle joey she is [__] this white
trash as you would expect her
i [__] love this [__] she is so
white dressed right
so
she's sitting at the table she's wearing
a [__] nightgown a moo moo smoking a
cigarette she's old country of [__]
smoking a cigarette right there at the
kitchen table and she'd have a record
plan and she just closed her eyes she
struggled with like addiction stuff and
uh
mental health [__] you know and i'd
watch her smoke that cigarette she'd
just be just she was happy and it's like
the only time i ever seen her like truly
escape the [__] you know
and uh i tell people if a doctor would
have helped my mom i might be a [__]
brain surgeon but music helped my mama
you know what i'm saying so music was
what i related to helping you know she
played these old classic motown records
backfield in motion
no it's against the rules and she just
be sitting there just smoking a
cigarette just backfield emotion you
know singing her little ass off and she
was just having a ball i don't know what
pills she was on but i know when that
song came on and she hit that cigarette
she was [__] whoo you know and i just
remember thinking man i want to make
people feel the way she feels like to
this day i listen to bad little rose and
i cry
because i think about my mother sitting
at that table just smoking a cigarette
smile and going play this at my funeral
baby jason play this one right here for
me boy this is the one it's the one you
know she just crank it louder you know
and i just i think about that stuff and
how music made her feel and i was like i
want to make people feel the way music
makes her feel you know
it's a good way of looking at it man but
no when you said about your options it's
so weird how
i was in the same boat we all feel like
we don't have a lot of options
especially when
our parents are dead or they don't have
money and we can't go to college
you know everybody you know if you don't
go to college you
you kind of not anymore because college
is a waste of [__] time now but when
i was going to school
if you didn't go to college nobody
really wanted to talk to you
right you know the biggest thing in the
70s was being like if you were a high
school dropout you might as well be a
[__] junkie
you know that was the
so
i quit high school you know then i got
the felonies i was a criminal
i was hooked on drugs and that's the
same thing you know we're limited you
know i really wanted to be a musician
but i know i would have pawned that
[__] guitar
yeah it doesn't take a genius to know
if i would have gotten to music i would
have been one of those guys that would
have to take this the [__] amp out of
doc
the guitar out of hawk like are we doing
a gig friday night i don't know i need
59 to get my [__] amp out of hawk i
was
always one of those guys that's why i
went for comedy because all you need is
a microphone
and three [__] you know
absolutely and then the microphones
provided and that's just
yeah that's right
so when you said that it's very uh
like this is what was handed to you
and yeah with the [__] thing
yeah i made a decision when i was 16
1 or 15 i'm not proud of that we had uh
we got caught up in a robbery case me
and a couple of couple of friends
and uh
i ended up being deemed as making
charges an adult
right then so i sat in the juvenile
detention facility here in nashville
i went the first time when i was 14 and
i came home at 15 when i came home from
the transitional center i ran ran away
or whatever and uh
caught a robbery case while i was out
went back in ran and caught a third case
there was a old robbery that came back
to haunt me and
i sat in that juvenile for like two two
and a half years the juvenile
penitentiary until the judge was like
nah we think he made the decision he was
in you know they charged me as an adult
probably 16 17 years
old and i went to the adult prison then
with a violent charge and in the state
of tennessee uncle joey
they don't forgive violent offenses
under no circumstance it's unexpungeable
down here like i need like a pardon or
something
so at that moment i was like
dude i'm never gonna you know
i'd already knew music what i wanted to
do but i knew
it was the streets of music at that
point i was i've been interested in my
life at that point i've already got hand
tattoos neck tattoos you know i'm all
the way there with it you know
so i was just like man i got to figure
this [__] out and i came home and got
riled up in a little more trouble and uh
had to go back and do to do the y2c one
more time i had to go do the texas two
step in the county jail a little bit
more
like i tell people i hadn't finished
touring the uh the fine prisons of the
state of tennessee at that point i
needed to see a couple more
and then i came home and while i was
gone i got a young woman pregnant on the
way out
on the way in
so when i came out the kid was two
hence the 14 year old that lives with me
now and that was the turning point for
me but yeah i just i felt option as much
i tell you all the time that uh our
stories were so similar you're like the
guy i always related to the most in that
world
because it was like you know
i didn't see nothing but this for me it
was just music it was like
i started selling mixed tapes out of the
trunk you know right here in nashville i
just like ride around when i got out of
jail and just sell mixtapes out of the
trunk and t-shirts and [__]
and here you are
here you [__]
you know you were so when you came out
and your daughter was two
what was your first what was the first
time you went into the studio
when was the first time you wrote a
lyric what were you feeling
i had a lot of stuff from jail where i
just sat in there for a couple years and
wrote you know i just wrote a bunch
and uh i'll send you the clip of the
video but i came home and my dude at the
time youtube was new
and i was so lucky i got to youtube
early uncle joey it was bad when you had
to go on a hard desktop computer type in
youtube you know cell phones or
and my dude had bought like one of these
little camcorders from um
my dude chad arms have bought a
camcorder from best buy or some [__]
like you know like an old standard like
you know digital but you know you still
flipped it you know sony cam or whatever
and
chad was like put on a beat in the
studio like fifth day out of jail
a little house studio the homie had and
he's like yo
rap to this jelly
so i've been in jail so i'm fired up
right and i'm just like rapping and just
i'm just talking [__]
well he ends up posting the clip on
youtube and back then it went viral this
is 10 11 years ago where viral back then
was like a couple hundred thousand views
you know this this was like you know
not long after [__] karate with uncle
joey right this is that era where like
little clips like it was so new to the
internet [__] was like you know
and ended up getting put on world star
hip-hop early in the world start hip-hop
days and that was kind of the beginning
of it launching some [__] for me and we
ended up having to take the video down
because in the video i have a famous
line where i say
if it's they called the 10-minute
freestyle but i said if my p.o.s i hang
drywall
well the [__] went viral enough my p.o
was like yo you can't be like making a
mockery of this [__] on the internet
like you gotta take this [__] down
so when i got off probation we put it
back up so i think the most recent
upload is still like eight years old
and it did a couple ended up doing a few
million views and it was off to the race
just from there man we just started
chasing the youtube thing you know
that's that's what it was like for
everybody i remember those days where if
you had like
20 000
downloads [__] you were like number
eight
uh literally youtube i'll never forget
being like number three
and oh yeah oh [__] i'm gonna get a boat
pretty soon i never got a boat
yeah who gives a [__] if you're number
three and number one
but i remember those days like people
would stop me on
those joey karate videos were [__]
listen man i was in chicago
i'd gotten [__] up the night before
i had to get on a plane a southwest
flight from midway to lax
i'm in the end i'm like i got to figure
something out with my [__] life and i
used to go to taekwondo on sunset
boulevard next to el compadre
and across from the guitar center
right there there's a uh right next to
the sunset grill which
don henley sang about right across the
street
is a mudda kwan taekwondo place on
sunset
i was bored one day i went in i had
studied that style in colorado so when i
moved to do comedy i saw it i'm like oh
my god
you have this in la and the guy's like
yeah come on it took me about two or
three four years to go in there i
finally went in and every time i would
be in there i was 400 pounds jelly
so every time i had the gear on you know
i'd be doing the forms and [__]
people would just be walking by like you
know
like minding their own business and all
of a sudden they would just look into
karate school and i'd see them go
what the [__] is that and they would
call the whole family over and they
would just stare at me
doing these moves with the [__] you
know
with my [__] chubby body and the
green belt and [__] so
i was coming back and i just said you
know what i'm gonna make a [__] video
today a joy karate video i've never done
it before as soon as i landed i called
my buddy from burbank airport and he
goes i'll meet you in 30 minutes at the
house i got home took a shower
boom we did our first joey karate video
and it was
[__] insane
it was really insane back then like
if you were a kid out of college you
know the kids come out and they go to
college they want to be a doctor but
then when they're in college they see
for you know they're in uh frats and
[__] and they all watch cyanide live so
then they get the entertainment bug
and they [__] shoot videos and [__]
dog i'm being in meetings
at networks with these other young kids
and all of us getting deals to [__]
shoot videos
that's how crazy it was back then it was
the real farm league
youtube was really a farm team
if you made it on youtube oh [__]
you were gonna [__]
and hey we did those joy karates
until they died and now people begged me
to do them again but it's over it's time
to move on [__] you don't go back
yeah it's like people tell me all the
time do the 10 minute freestyle again
i'm like listen man
i'll never have that much to say that
fast again i had been sitting in a
[__] 6x8 cell for two years i had a
lot of wraps in my head you know i was
like [__] you i had been entertaining
the place every friday for [__] 100
weeks i was ready to let it all loose
you know
you would entertain people in jail would
you rap and [__] and [__] around
oh yeah man we would uh we'd do
freestyle fridays and they would have
this utility room right
and i would uh i'd walk into the utility
room with my sport because they give you
a plastic sport when you first walked in
like instead of giving you silverware
every day you got a sport when you came
it's like part of your [__] you know
like you keep this [__] this is
your weight only
if you use it your couple right you know
so i'd go in there with my sport
and i would um
the utility room had a microwave or
whatever
everything's plexiglass and i'd go beat
on the plexiglass window
man uncle joey this one i knew i was on
or something right i'd go
and i do it by the bottom i do it third
time the third time i go
so by the time i got to the beat doom
doom you would watch them start running
in right i wouldn't announce that i just
go doom doom doom
by the time i got that last that that
sixth doom the room would be filling up
and i just start rapping right
and i'd be singing the choruses and then
i wrap the verses and then i'd sing the
chorus and i passed it to like anybody
i'd be like all right you look like such
and such you know and then he wrapped
and then i'd cut him off and i'd bring
the chorus back in like make like you
know it was a thing and it was like they
knew it on friday man when i walked in
there with that sport they just start
piling in
because there's only so much room in the
utility room so everybody's trying to
get in here and people out there
watching they're standing on tables it
was crazy and i was like yo this [__]
might work now keep in mind i'm like
one of three white dudes in a 220 man
unit
you know when i tell people i'm still
from the era where especially in hip-hop
you throw a rock right now and you hit a
white dude that can rap right you know
everything you know i know i live in the
country music capital of america and
these country music dudes oh every time
i get drunk with them like i be rapping
too you know they want to rap to me you
know
and it's uh in my era no sir nobody
there was very few white rappers the
beastie boys
eminem was bubbling we had a guy named
haystack down here this was even before
bubba sparks had put out his first [__]
you know
it wasn't
if you was a white dude that rap you
better be one really good and two you
better have a bunch of black dudes
standing beside you going oh this is our
guy
you know
so for me to go in there and rock that
place man i mean i was rocking the
violent offender gang unit
of the prison
like the killers was just in there like
riding with me like yo this white boy is
crazy you know what i'm saying i'm
singing these super soulful choruses
though you know what i mean
and then it just kind of connected when
i came home
i played with it before but when i came
home i was like
no we're going all in
because i played with it one time
when i made bond at 17 my father god
rest his soul came and bonded me out
and i called him the day they
transferred me from juvenile to the
adult jail
and i had a radio in jail and the radio
was like sunday night out of limits
freestyle battle
thousand dollars cash prize right
so when i called my dad i'm like hey man
come get me i'm gonna give you a
thousand dollars back sunday it was like
i was like yeah i just gotta you know i
will i need you to buy me out i need to
borrow a hundred dollars because i need
to sign up for it because it's like a
hundred dollar entry fee you know and i
was like and then i i'll give you the
other you know the money and i'll go win
this thing
and i had the most loving dad and mother
because they just believed me like it
wasn't like some kid that was saying
weird [__] to them like they knew how
much i believed in myself
so he was like okay
i went joey i snuck in because i was
underage i won that [__] freestyle
battle i went in there and won that
thousand dollars and it was a ten week
competition i won it for the next nine
weeks it was like a job every sunday i
would go to the [__] black club and
just roast people
just smoked them and then of course my
bond got violated and back i went there
goes the revolving door of the jail but
yeah so i mean i knew i was always into
it it just started working it's so funny
how now that i think about listening to
your story about jail and my story
man that's a great way to [__]
develop as a performer
because you always got a [__]
audience you know what i'm saying that
ain't got nothing else to do you can
either sit in your room or come listen
to my [__] stinky jokes until they
get better and even with music i'll go
in there with a ukulele i play a [__]
ukulele for some of those brothers by
the time they're gonna have to all be
listening to don ho i don't give a [__]
cause it's the truth you're always gonna
have eight people to watch it they're
bought as [__] you can only watch so
much [__]
bobby flay and so much [__] america's
most wanted so
food thought for you young performers
out there think big think jail first
your story will be a lot [__] better
like ours
did you develop the comedy routine in
there a little bit did you start getting
the storytelling in there i
never [__] dreamt of doing stand-up
comedy and a week before i got arrested
a guy i hated more than [__] anal sex
came up to me and he's like hey man i
know you don't like
me he goes do you know what i did before
i came to work here and i have no
[__] idea i just didn't like the guy
and he goes i was in entertainment in
vegas
i hired comedians and musicians
and he goes i'm not blowing smoke up
your ass you'd be a great comedian i'm
like get the [__] away from me like i
was still young stupid
like get the [__] away from me you know
and then
i kind of thought about it then i got
arrested
then i came out on bail and i was just
trying to get my life together there was
no stand-up [__] comedy you know
and then when i got sentenced uh it took
about a month to go to a destination
like to go to the prison that you go to
diagnostic and then the prison they find
the prison for you they sent me to a
[__] camp
like a work camp you know and uh
they did little activities and on
thursday nights had movie night they
would play like pt109 they never played
a movie you wanted to see they were all
black and white movies and [__]
and the projector would always break and
when the projector would break the
[__] guys would go
cuba go up there and talk [__] because i
worked in the kitchen
in the jail which is the best job in the
jail
it was me and 13 brothers i had a guy
edgy
that all he wanted to do was work on his
freezes because he says if he's in jail
for too long to freeze won't sound you
know like when he'd go freeze so he come
in the kitchen and go freeze i tell him
when to say it and all the [__]
prisoners will hit the floor and [__] it
was [__] tremendous
i would tell the prisoners with the food
sucked
when they would come on the line there
was a few of my friends and i would just
yell out don't do it
don't do it and they knew to run back to
their room and get an apple and a bag of
chips so i was building like a
personality in the kitchen
like just being me [__] around i
didn't want to be a stand-up
and when the projector would break
they'd go cuba get up there
and talk about people there was one
black dude in the kitchen
that nobody really liked even the black
dudes didn't like him he was like one of
those orange brothers with freckles and
[__]
[Laughter]
and they used to [__] pay me to go
off on them and the guy listen the guy
was tougher than death he wasn't there
for murder
but thank god the guy had a sense of
humor he was bored as [__] you know what
i'm saying
when you make somebody laugh in prison
it means a little more like people have
no idea
especially when they came up to me and
said dog why are you always so happy
people don't like people in prison that
are happy
yeah and i'm like well they're gonna
have to suck my dick because this is who
i am what do you want me to sit here and
walk around with a mean face all [__]
day you know and
it was like eight thursdays in a row i
went up
and for the first time after like the
10th like the fifth wednesday i thought
about it thursday i'm like
maybe i do have a korean stand-up comedy
and i'm like i'm like that's never going
to happen you know none of that shit's
going to happen for me and it wasn't to
the librarian who was in there for
killing his wife and the mailman he came
home from work and he found the mailman
[__] his wife
so he killed the wife then he blasted
the mailman which made it a federal case
tremendous
[Music]
that's why shoot the mailman they'll
send you to a better prison [__]
always shoot the mailman so
[Laughter]
you'll end up up in lompoc riding horses
and playing tennis with gangsters eating
[__] cop italian [__] like that
so when he told me that i should get
into comedy he gave me a notebook and he
goes if you don't get into comedy by the
time i get out i'm gonna come down and
kill you
so for years i was ready for this
[__] to come to one of my shows
obviously he must have killed another
mailman in jail because i haven't seen
this [__] at all so
and that's how i got into it that's how
i [__] got into it
but i
let me ask you something are you happy
that you went to jail
um
you know i've this is the way i thought
about this
i think that it
paved the path for where i ended up
and i'm not i'm not proud of the things
i did that made me end up in jail
you know
but i i i do think that carves the path
i don't think i'd have been who i am
today had i not went through every part
of the journey
including the [__] up [__] like jail
it made it gave me the closest thing to
character
and uh discipline and integrity i ever
had you know i had to learn how to
politic
you know that you was in there
like i've learned how to pop dude i
wasn't juvenile at [__] 14. you know
there's 17 year old
dudes in there [__] bench pressing
baby mammoths with beards
i'm [__] 14. you know what i'm saying
i [__] you know i don't have a i
don't have one piece of hair on my dick
yet right my dick my balls haven't
dropped i still got this voice you know
what i'm in there with dudes that
[__] look like they're [__]
people's moms and [__] you know in the
juvenile penitentiary and i had to learn
how to politic and move in a room full
of vultures
and it taught me a lot about
that and it helped me develop the craft
too i'd never
i told this to my daughter recently
uncle joey i said listen
because you know she's a songwriter now
and i said baby listen
i can write a thousand songs with you
but i can't write a thousand songs for
you
and if i could i already did it because
i wrote thousands of songs you know and
uh
dude i wrote
thousands of songs in jail i mean
hundreds and hundreds of songs in jail
you know just but like you what else the
[__] else was i going to do that's
another thing if you're going to
play if you want to write an album go to
jail
generate the best [__] album in the
world you got no
nobody's bothering you you could try
your jokes on the cooks you could break
the jokes that night next time i do a
special if i ever do i'm going to jail
for a year that's probably the best
[__] special you've ever heard in
your goddamn life
[Laughter]
we should just go be cell mates for a
year nobody's calling you nobody's
bothering you nope right it's like if i
had to learn who i was
because you know you so much time you're
spending just here just having to deal
with you you know
and uh i definitely you know i think it
definitely gave me a lot of the charisma
i have because i had to move around you
know i had the shock i had to move a
little bit there joey you know i got in
some hairy spots you know
i was running canteen and peddling a
little weed in there a little coke you
know i had a little thing going so i was
you know i was learning how to politic
with all sides but uh i hate what i went
through to get there but uh i'm glad
that it worked out for me you know
i always tell people going to prison let
me know what i didn't want to do
i tell people all the time i think the
worst that they could do for you to you
as a man
is kick your bed and tell you to wake
the [__] up
nobody knows how much that bothers me
a man will if a woman wants to kick the
bed and put a piece of [__] on me wake
me up [__] wake me up before you go go
you know what i'm saying
i want to eat that monkey
[__] slow slow
so
it's just weird that
when a man kicks your [__] bed and
says get the [__] up you sack of [__]
that's a reality in prison
and that was one thing i said to myself
nobody's ever going to do that to me
again
and then they make you stand up just to
make your bed and then you can lay back
down yeah then you lay back down
i was scared of spending the rest of my
life in jail but i knew i wasn't going
to take [__] from those people in that
you know
and it was fine after a month i got
along with everybody but that's what i'm
grateful to go to jail because
it let me know it
told me what i needed to do what i had
to do and it also let me know
the things i didn't want to do anymore
that you're not supposed to do as a man
i don't give a [__] what they tell you
you know i was sad going to jail and
seeing these people talking about and
you've seen this gels people talking
about all the jails they've been to
like they went on tour
oh yeah they did a [__] national tour
i went to red rocks i did the garden i
did [__]
atlanta these guys will sit there for
hours and tell you all the jails you've
been thinking and they'll start telling
you what they liked about what they
liked about them all they were like yo
the food over there was banging oh my
god
they're just like what yeah they've got
cable what you don't have cable at home
you gotta go to [__] jail for cable
yeah
i'll tell you i was in some good jails
though dog i was in boulder county jail
that was voted number one jail in
colorado that [__] had
carpets
cable tv and kool-aid and
they let you talk on the phone
until
if
the dorm was up till one they let you
talk on the phone until one
wow
long-distance calls too i was calling
everybody all over i was calling china
and japan
i didn't give a [__] those states get
good rates on their phone services
you know what changed it for me joey
when i walked in
and
whenever i the bond thing came out and i
had to go back to the adult jail
and i went into the time came home and
violated again the last time i went
when i was an intake
a guy that i was in juvenile with
eight years before that right nine years
before his uncle joey comes and sees
like what's up jelly man i'm like oh
[__] i didn't see you says we were in
such a juvenile spot
he was like yeah yeah you know they
telling me right there they're trying to
classify you to the unit you know the
you know where all the the [__] is you
know i just because of my charges
previous i knew where i was going i go
there every time
so i'm like yeah who was over there he's
like bro everybody we was in the
juvenile penitentiary with and at that
moment i was like because he was happy
to tell me that like oh you're gonna
love it it's a family reunion and it hit
me in a way uncle joy where i was like
man i gotta break this man
like this is you know i became a part of
the revolving door
you know what i'm saying where it's like
you know when you're getting a reception
in the local jail from guys you've been
locked up with on and off for 10 years
they're like jelly rolls here what's
that big dog you know and they're like
and of course i'm just like man this
[__] ain't i gotta change this and i
ain't been back and do that i go back
now
um i go to the juvenile once every three
months and talk and do like a seminar
and i'll send them pizzas and i'm i'm
currently working to build a studio in
that juvenile that i was in for all
those years
but besides going back to see talk to
people man i've been man i hadn't had a
crossword with a law officer in [__]
[__] 10 years third 12 years
it's been close to the last time i got a
ticket which had to be
20 years ago
that's the last time i had you know
police contact trouble it's been since
yeah
that you know and and you just
if you're at home watching this listen
man
you get in trouble you get caught by
drugs it's a [__] rotating door me
and jelly will tell you all [__] day
long but
you get stronger sometimes
you get stronger and you go i don't want
to do this anymore and that night you
end up doing a gram of coke
that's okay
because you're heading in the right
direction
yes once you acknowledge all this [__]
that what you're missing and what you
should be doing
you're heading in the right direction it
takes a while
i mean
jelly roll you're talking about all this
[__]
and you're at the precipice of you know
blowing
your talent like you're a [__] huge
talent
you know what are your influences
i'm very curious to find out here
so
i was the baby i have a i have two older
brothers and an older sister
and my sister's my older sister's
boyfriend uh husband now has been with
her since i was like two so i always had
him in the house and uh
because of being the baby i never got to
control the radio right
so
i think that's what makes my sound so
unique is you know what i'm listening
when i'm hanging out with mama we're
listening to like motown
you know what i mean we're listening to
uh sitting in the mountains
when the evening comes i get in the car
with pops and he's but he's bumping
james taylor
right or like kenny g
he was singer songwriter he likes softer
music like kill like jazz or like
uh james taylor jim croche you know all
those classic singer songwriters
and then i get in the car with my
brother and he's nothing but tupac right
he's like gangster rapped out like my
older brother you know and then i get in
the car with my sister and she's
listening to nothing but metallica the
black album
nothing but you know like like all this
rock and metal and i i never got to get
in the car and say what i want to listen
to i'm the baby right you know i'm look
i'm i'm the baby of the house
so every time i would get in the car
because you know i'm from an era i joke
with my daughter all the time she walks
around with her [__] iphone you know
player music you know
she'll be in one room her iphone playing
music bunnies my wife's in another room
iphone playing music you know we take
music everywhere now in my era you
listen to music one or two [__]
places in the car or in the house and
that was if you was rich enough to buy
the cd or cassette tape twice
you know what i mean you could have a
cassette or you had this transfer with
you you know
so every time i we'd ride or something i
just listened to different musics and i
was kind of influenced by all of it i
went to lollapalooza in 97.
snoop dogg my sister took me
snoop dogg
tool
corn and prodigy are planned
okay
and i remember watching it go from snoop
dogg to corn
to tool
and thinking man
i want to do all that like right then i
just was like
and i remember how well it went over
this is 97.
you know people act like genre blending
is like a new thing now you know it's
like dude this is 1997.
i watched snoop dogg come out literally
between prodigy
and [__] corn
you know what i mean this is the highest
dog this is 97 snoop dogg this is like
the year after pak dad this is gangster
party this is you know
jenna's new snoop dogg this is like
snoop dogg you know it was the case that
they gave me snoop dogg this is that
snoop dogg
pinnacle snoop you know and
he shut that [__] down
and he smoked a joint on stage you know
back then that was like he might as well
have been shooting heroin in front of
everybody in 97 in nashville in the
bible belt you know what i mean he might
as well just do been doing big stripes
of cocaine in front of the whole world
you know
and uh
he comes off stage and then corn comes
out and this is corn you know adidas
corn all day i dream about sex [__] this
is like that corn you know and i just
like
just watched it and i was like man
this is crazy i just left so inspired i
was like i want to do that
you know that's what i told my sister
then and
it's funny it was at an amphitheater
and this is this year besides this east
coast run i'm fixing to do which is club
dates from last year i played nothing
but amphitheaters the rest of the year
ain't that crazy joey that's right crazy
that's crazy
dude 25 years removed from going to my
first show ever which was at an
amphitheater i'm playing i'm like holy
[__] man this [__] [__] is panning
out that's crazy
as of today uncle joey we got the number
six song on uh popular rock radio dead
man walkers is the number six on the
popular rock radio
i got a song called son of a center that
just broke into the top 50 on country
radio so
we're flying baby
now who what's the ban sms
dead man walking with
who'd you do with somebody because
that's
i had heard you early on you reached out
to me
and i heard one of your songs but i
thought it was like a wrap you did it
with somebody else
yeah well
um
i forgot which one it was i'd had a
freestyle too that i that we met each
other on twitter over kashab and
reposted it right and uh
i shouted you out because i've been such
a joey fan forever this was a few years
back and i remember i said uh
mad flavors like joey what's happening
now
[Laughter]
and even back then joey retweeted it and
put there you
there you go
but
the [__] i heard two weeks ago on octane
i i i couldn't even get out of the car
oh dude thank you when you when you
listen to music and you don't want you
know somebody called me the other day oh
how about this my agent called me
and i said to her i can't [__]
believe i was listening to california
love
and it was the part where tupac's about
to throw out on jail a shot of bail
and all of a sudden my agent called and
i told i just said i go you just [__]
up the tupac
solo on california love she goes you
want me to call you back and go no it's
halfway [__] over by now
but
i'll tell you the day listening to your
uh
to your uh octane
blew me the [__] away
i think it was dead man walking save me
yeah is that it save me as a
jam
i think smoking section and only were on
there uh
because they did the live thing right
did you catch the one where i did all
the laughs yeah
yeah so i know that uh that smoking
section on there that i hope that heaven
has a smoking section
yeah
the high school people get that too your
voice was so [__] soulful i heard
johnny cash i heard motown in your voice
i heard
i just heard so many emotions and your
soul
comes to your voice the gift that god
gave you jelly
is that you know some people say you
wear your heart on your sleeve
you wear your your voice on your soul
brother it's a connection
so
i [__] love you to death i love what
you're doing
i'm going to come and see you in dc
we're going to get at the dc show
bring [__] mike with me too leave
them down there give them a [__]
edible and [__] yeah yeah i'll bring
some 200 milligrams abx v and some joey
coco weed
yes baby but
i want you to tell these [__]
where they can find your schedule
because you know i love you joint
don't miss out on this young man because
in three years you're not gonna afford
to see him
this is what you wanna see
jelly roll now on the way up because
when his tickets are 400 don't come
[__] crying to me then kelly won't
let me [__] you where were you when he
was at the festival with kiss i told you
about it [__] march you [__] suckers
so if you're anywhere in that louisville
section
make sure you catch my man that's a
[__] great show
that's a great [__] weekend so
that's the weekend that's gonna [__]
you're on stage with legends that's it
you just become a legend by proxy yes
sir yes sir uh
jellyroll615.com uncle joey i'm
jellyroll625 on pretty much every
platform just type in jellyroll on
youtube i think i don't know what it is
on there but you'll find me i'm verified
dude i'm everywhere i mean some type of
you know how long it took me to [__]
beat jelly roll morton in the [__]
pastry on google years so you can film
[__] years
so it is
[Laughter]
finally i'm pretty findable we're
releasing more tour dates uh over you
know we announced red rocks this morning
uh october it's in october i got a big
nashville show i'm announcing in a
couple of weeks and uh huge tours man
we're just announcing stuff every day
this is like this is crazy i'm gonna
talk to you about the national show
right before we went as soon as we get
offline but uh i want you to come down i
was talking to shop man i want to get
some of my my comedian homies to come
come make an appearance and host it it's
gonna be big it's a non-profit thing i'm
doing to build the studio in the
juvenile okay
you know my in-laws lived that
oh yeah just came back my wife just got
back so i could go to nashville all i
gotta do is just say i feel like going
to nashville my wife is on
yeah
and we'll go to lee's fried chicken and
show those [__]
how to eat because that's my chicken
joint right there down close to milan
and that one in louisville too
yes sir yeah louisville
so if i go to that festival we'll be
hitting that [__] lee's fried
[__] chicken
i love that chicken you guys don't know
what chicken is until you eat lies from
[__] feliz fried chicken
jelly you need something you call that's
oh i know it man thank you i love you
aunt man it's meant the world to me to
do this as a family oh my god it feels
good to go from a fan to family baby
that's the hey baby i'm a fan of yours
and i will [__] family so
stay in touch stay black and i love you
brother love you brother
baby thank you for coming on the joint
today
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed
jelly roll he's great uh i'm gonna go
see him in dc
if you guys get a chance to go see him
in [__] louisville that that show
looks
tremendous we're kissing a bunch of
people
and uh that's it and that's that man i
want to thank you for another fun-filled
week
on the [__] joint thank you for
supporting us
you know thank you for always having our
back and thank you for always thinking
about us i love you [__] have a
great week and now for a word my
[__] sponsor jack
all right i want to thank my man jelly
roll again six one five
for uh [__] doing a great job today
and for even holding my attention he's a
great artist
give him a list and support him
and i'd like to thank all of you for the
support you give me before we leave
i need to tell you a little word from my
sponsors from the heart of new jersey to
join is brought to you by draftkings
listen it's the biggest college
basketball tournament you're sitting on
the sidelines and draftking sportsbook
is waiting for you turn your team's
victory
into your win you know where you went to
college bet them i don't give a [__]
what you do new customers can bet five
hours on any team to win and get two
miles in free bets when they do if they
win you win if sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet then you can
still join the college hoop action with
draftkings pools these are the best
everyone can play for free
the whole month of march to win a share
over 250 000 in prizes so do me a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey j-o-e-y
bet five dollars on any college hoop
team to win and get 200 and free bets
when they do
if they win you win i win your mother
wins everybody wins use promo code joey
this week and let's get in on the
college basketball actions you got to be
21 over and restrictions do apply the
joint is also brought to you by cbd lion
when it comes to cbd the lion is the
best how do i know because i live it
they even have delta nine gummies now
they have tincture they got regular
gummies with melatonin they got the cbd
cream
kinesiology tape if you got a [__]
problem cbd lion's got the answer go to
cbdlion.com right now
pressing code joey
or join and get 20 off your first order
i'm over here taking care of you people
cbd lion ko joey
the joint is also brought to you by
relief ban listen there's plenty to be
anxious about today so when i say relief
ban helps with my anxiety you know it's
the real [__] deal all right relief
ban has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and prevent nausea and
vomiting how do you deal with nausea
from motion sickness migraines hangovers
and morning sickness or chemo relief
band helps with that too it's like the
name says it's a ban you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea
caused by things like anxiety you change
the intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
when i had the surgery relief band was
there for me i wore it every day it
helps with the recuperation it helps
with the [__] nausea
relief ban is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
and provides long-lasting relief with
zero side effects nothing
and now that they just released the
relief banned sport it's waterproof has
an extended battery life and attaches to
your apple or android watch listen
relief band makes a great gift for any
time of the year whether you have an
uncle and grandparents
they might be going through chemo
morning sickness maybe they hung over
who the [__] knows you're lucky if your
grandpa is still hungover give them
relief band that makes a great gift and
right now they got an exclusive offers
for the joint listeners if you go to
reliefband.com
use promo code joey you're going to
receive 20 off
plus free shipping is a no question ass
30 day money back guarantee that's the
best offer you'll find on relief band
anywhere
so head over to reliefband.com and use
promo code joey j-o-e-y for 20 off and
free shipping i want to thank relief
band i want to thank draftking cbd lion
blue chew
unbelievable zip recruiter
you name it we got it over here on the
joint i love you [__] have a
happy saint patty's day have a great
weekend and i'll see you [__]
monday morning tip top magoo
love you
[Music]
you